Let's go next to our caller from the four
zero five area code.
Who's calling today from four zero five?
Uh, yes, this is stone.
Hey stone.
What's up?
Uh, Hey, David.
Um, so to kind of set up my question, um,
nowadays we have just incredible technology.
Um, you know, we have the technology to provide
clean energy, renewable energy, uh, you know,
uh, create clean water, uh, vertical farms,
three D printed homes, uh, things of that
nature.
And it seems like the problem is that programs
like this never pick up or uh, expand because
they are not profitable.
How do we change people's mindset?
So they are willing to buy in towards programs
that would help them, but they only ever see
that initial cost.
I don't know that I agree that they're not
profitable, they're just profitable for different
people.
Let me give you some examples.
Um, and, and a lot of this is speculative
and we're just not going to know for a few
years.
So vertical farming, for example, huge promise.
But what's the advantage to vertical farming?
Vertical farming can be done
enabled
vertical space often inside of a building,
including an urban centers.
If you're a farmer in the Midwest, vertical
farming is not profitable for you because
you're in the Midwest with huge fields, not
in an urban area with a building where you
would actually do it.
So vertical farming is profitable for different
people.
The normal farming is profitable.
For another example that you mentioned, three
D printing homes, three D printing homes,
the technology, it's still early in that technology.
I mean, you know, we've seen modular become
more of a thing.
Uh, but three D printing is different.
The people who would benefit from three D
printing homes are not the people who can
currently control the building industry and
big builders and contractors.
So it's not that it's economically not viable
to three D print homes, although it's still
expensive today because we've not scaled yet.
But the people who would benefit from it are
different than the ones who currently control
that industry.
So I just think that what your ne, your assessment
is right, that there are misaligned incentives,
but it's not that it's just not profitable
to go in these new directions is that it's
going be profitable for different people than
the ones that currently control those industries.
Okay.
Um, I guess kind of a short followup question,
um, I mean, if, if we, you know, we have the
power to end homelessness and end hunger
[inaudible]
we, we have the technology to do it, so, so
why doesn't it happen?
Lack of political will and that we've talked
about a lot.
There's a lack of political will.
Um, uh, always having another election around
the corner is a disincentive to deal with
some of these bigger picture issues that we
can solve except that there's not really the
political will to do it.
Uh, that that's a systemic problem, which,
uh, which I've talked about many times before.
Stone, thank you for the phone call.
I really appreciate hearing [inaudible]
you.
Thank you.
All right, we'll take a quick break if you
are holding, don't hang up because we will
go right back to the phones after this short
break.